thank you for your time also quable the
actor i'm excited to see that movie
whenever oh yeah never seen talk about
none of the actions yeah you want to
plug it tell me about you tell me about
the actors
john malkovich you know what i'm saying
um
it's a movie called watch me in the
river
and um i'm excited it's one of my first
you know what i'm saying movies like an
action drummer yeah it's gonna take you
through a roller coaster you're gonna be
sad you're gonna be crying
then you're gonna
see me yeah
is this like is it a pretty big big role
yes it's a big role my boy coyote i'm
coyote
how hard is it memorize the lions or did
it come easy to you
uh i was there for like a month i think
they were shooting we was shooting in
puerto rico
and um
i just made sure i was just
trying to like
be organic as possible because they
wouldn't tell you when you kind of like
mess up and i thought that was like
a bad thing yeah so i was like they're
not telling me what i was doing they're
not telling me it's like they mean
you're doing something good because if
if you messing up they'll get they'll do
a thousand takes until they get it right
so i was just going and just like go in
like twice or three times and then just
be done for the day
and then they were telling me i was
killing it that's great so so when i see
the movie
i'm gonna
hopefully kill it yeah so i don't know
how this works well you get to see at
least some type of cut of it before
okay yeah i seen cuts i seen cuts did
you love it i got chills
oh my goodness good job i did a good job
wait okay so do we know when does this
come out
uh i don't know when to date i don't
want to be wrong so yeah yeah but i mean
like you worked with robert de niro on a
movie that's like pretty
no that's huge that's huge i had to tell
my mom that one yeah what'd she say
she went crazy damn wayne she went crazy
do you like hit anyone up for acting
tips or you were just like i'ma go in
there and do this and see what they tell
me and i just pay attention to like rob
dinero i paid attention to um jack
houston i was just watching them to
watch how serious they get right before
the camera you know i'm saying right
before they say action how they like
just try to channel something and uh and
i was just kind of putting that together
and just trying to just
calm down and get you know what i'm
saying get to get the butterflies out
and just watch people in front of me i'm
pretty good with that yeah oh my gosh
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna be watching
so actor
rapper
producer is there a fourth thing we have
to add to this uh in five years no you
gotta ask my athletic
oh yes i'm an athlete but i'm just not
an elite athlete so is there a feeling
you gotta be in the lead to be athlete
right totally agree okay cool is there a
fifth thing we're gonna add to this in
five years fifth thing
in five years yep
[ __ ] billionaire billionaire we're
speaking it yeah gotta add that gotta
add that b for sure no thank you this
was so much fun thanks for coming thank
you
[Music]